all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things youtube channel today
i am in the middle of moving so this
isn't like a super professional video
but i just had to give my two cents so
today i just got the news that dangerous
misogynist andrew tate booted from
instagram and facebook
controversial online influencer and
self-described misogynist andrew tate
has been banned from meta platforms
instagram and facebook the former
kickboxer and reality tv star was
removed for violating meta policies on
dangerous organizations and individuals
the company confirmed by email tate's
first tate first rose to prominence
after appearing on tv and the show big
brother in 2016 where he was removed
from the series after the video of him
beating a woman outside the show suffice
i'm pretty sure that was like a
this is the thing
you know i'm gonna go back to that since
then he has garnered backlash for his
post across social media which domestic
abuse charities have called extreme
misogyny he stated on twitter in 2017
that women belong in the home and that
great victims bear responsibilities for
their attack after twitter permanently
banned him from the platform tate has
grown a following for his advice videos
to men many of them have sexist
territories on one youtube video tate
described himself as an absolute
misogynist he said i'm a realist and
when you're a realist you're sexist
there's no way you can be rooted in
reality and not be sexist in the
statement of the guardian tate
characterized many of his videos as
parody stating he was playing a comedic
character internet sensationalism has
perpet
um has per pitch purpo to the idea that
anti-semitic when women when nothing
could be further from the truth he said
adding that he has donated to charities
benefiting women i am genuinely innocent
tate was a vocal supporter of former
president donald trump has appealed on a
number have has appeared on a number of
right-wing podcasts including shows like
infowars hosted by alex jones more
recently tate has become impossible to
avoid on social media and the time of
his ban from meta platforms he has
gained more than 4.7 million followers
on instagram
tic tac has also banned tate's official
account on their platforms and is
working to remove content related to him
that violates guidelines videos using
hashtags related to tate have been seen
more than
12.7 billion times
misogyny is a hateful ideology that is
not tolerated on tick tock a tick tock
spokesperson said we've been removing
videos
and accounts for weeks and we welcome
the new other platforms taking action
against this individual so let's talk i
am a woman okay and i am no [ __ ] i am
not offended in any way by the [ __ ] that
andrew tates says
the reason that society is trying to
silence him is because women are pissed
off they're pissed off that he is
telling the truth about women and he is
telling the truth about intersexual
dynamics and he is giving a voice to men
that don't feel hurt in our society
because we live in a gynocentric social
order that caters to women at every
single need that they possibly have
women are bailed out of every bad
decision that we make
and
andrew tate was just bringing light to
that and the reason they take his [ __ ]
out of context and try to make him sound
like a woman hating a misogynist is
because
they don't like that he's bringing
reality to the forefront and taking
power away from women by telling the
truth about our nature
women are built out of every bad
decision that we make if we
sleep around what happens
we have birth control if we use birth
control we have abortion if we have
abortion
and we end up homeless we there's
women's shelters
like there we are always build out of
bad decisions and when tate was coming
to the forefront and saying telling men
that it is okay to have standards you
don't have to date fat women you don't
have to date old women and you don't
have to date single mothers
and i don't take those women seriously
and you don't have to either
men are allowed to have standards ladies
i'm sorry
look at i'm 25 and andrew tate said i'm
too old today after 20 i'm about to turn
26. like
got three more months
and that's okay
that's okay it's not misogynistic it's
not hate speech it doesn't mean that
they hate women it just means that the
world is harsh
and women don't want men to know about
what are real prices
because they're they're trying to sell a
used car for new prices and men aren't
having it anymore they're seeing the
forest through the trees
and
this
[ __ ] about hate speech is
literally just their way of trying to
silence men
and it's not going to work
because there's women like me speaking
out that aren't with this [ __ ] there's
more when you what do they say when you
when you try to cut one ahead off like
to grow
it's not going to work
and he he's showing re he's showing the
world for what it is and the other thing
is they take so much [ __ ] out of context
like they were trying to say
the video of him abusing a girl was like
a
okay i'm not into that kind of stuff you
know in bed but
that's that's to each his own and the
girl came forward and said that yeah we
were just playing around that wasn't it
like like low-key i like that [ __ ]
and
now
now you're going to take that out of
context even though she came forward and
said that
look at
i'm a woman andrew tate is not sexist
there is some [ __ ] he does i don't
really agree with he had a party where
he invited all of his girlfriends
together
i wouldn't do that i wouldn't do that i
wouldn't really want to have a family
where the dude is cheating all the time
but that's the man has worked his whole
life to earn the right to do that and if
he wants to do that that's fine
it's not misogynistic it doesn't mean he
hates women
it means that he is a powerful man that
wants to do what he wants to do and the
women want to do it too
so who
cares
who cares it's not misogynistic he
doesn't hate women
and the other thing they take out of
context is he says that 18 and 19 year
olds are more attractive physically
because they haven't been with as many
people
as i'm about to be 26 that's 26 year old
that's true when i was 18 and 19 i was
virgin i'm not a virgin now it's more
attractive to be a virgin
it's not fun but reality is going to hit
you in the face at some point and you
can you get ladies can either live in
delusion
and demand men love you as how you are
or try to become what they want those
are those are your choices
and you can live in delusion and just
say i can sleep with as many people as i
want i can get as fat as i want i can
have kids with another dude and
someone's going to accept me or you can
listen to the men and say hmm maybe i
should change to become more of what
they want
and
it is crazy how they will silence people
that disagree i just got my tic tac
account taken look i'm on just pearly
things number two so go follow it just
pearly things too
and
i'm not massaging i'm a woman you can't
say that i hate women
so
they can they can try to silence the
messenger
but if anything this is just going to
bring more attention to the message
and
the message is that men are allowed to
have standards
men deserve to be heard
and
like stop stop listening to these hoes
stop stop listening to these hoes they
don't even know what they want so
anyways like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel sign up for our
memberships we're moving alright
i am moving into a pet house if you want
to get the behind-the-scenes look sign
up for membership tier number two you'll
see the first look at the behind the
scenes vlogs i'll talk to you next time
bye